wir haben hier vor allen dingen die
letzten minuten gestritten über den satz
der kanzlerin es ist im großen und
ganzen nichts schief gelaufen das war
ihre antwort auf die frage nach den
impfstoff bestellungen in der
europäischen union ist dass der satz der
ihnen ganz besonders im gedächtnis
geblieben ist oder was ganz anderes aus
diesen 15 minuten interview
das passt es doch schon ganz gut
zusammen also es klappt nirgendwo klappt
wir haben keinen impfstoff
gesundheitsämter desaströse das zustand
in altenheim mit gestorben aber im
großen und ganzen sagt die regierung
auch die leitung alles prima gelaufen
herr fleischhauer frau merkel sagt alles
prima keine fehler wurden gemacht was
hätten sie sich denn heute von frau
merkel gewünscht in der kommunikation
kommunikation wird ein großes wort
ich glaube viele leute hätten wir ganz
gerne gewusst wie es weitergeht über den
14 februar hinaus
und da habe ich wenig gehört dass nicht
mal so die praktischen fragen
jetzt gibt es eine impf angeboten paar
kollegen haben ja zurecht nachgefragt
was heißt eigentlich impfangebot heißt
impfangebot dass man dann einen
impftermin irgendwann bekommt oder wird
auch heißt im angebot auch impftermin
noch im sommer das war mir auch nicht so
ganz klar
ich hoffe man letzteres dritte angebote
sind so ein paar technische begriffe die
da drin sind auch dynamischer im sparen
können sie damit was anfangen
dynamischer geplant aber ich habe immer
wenn die politiker zu so ganz
komplizierten satz ungetüm kommen dann
hat man doch dass da irgendwie ist darum
geht was zu verbergen
also der große auftritt frontfrau von
der leyen beim zdf herrn klaus claus
kleber wo sie dann irgendwie auch sich
letztlich darauf zurück dass sie die
prozentrechnung irgendwie entglitten ist
dann weiß man jetzt wird echt aber
dynamischer im plan ist doch eigentlich
ganz einfach zu verstehen das ist halt
einen impfplan den mann aber ständig
wieder verändern kann wenn man denn ja
das problem ist halt dass wir haben dass
wir komplett als abhängig gemacht haben
von anderen
und das hat ja die ganze auch
angesprochen ganz interessant sie sagte
ja ja die amerikaner behalten ja all
ihren impfstoff bei sich pfizer lässt
nichts außer landes und wir sagen heute
darauf angewiesen was in europa
produziert wird ja das ist so aber ich
glaube die frage hätte man sich eben
auch im letzten herbst vorstellen können
wie viele produktionsanlagen gibt es
eigentlich in europa oder ganz
grundsätzlich ist es euch in unserem
interesse dass biontech zusammen geht
mit einem amerikanischen konzern
das heißt ein konzern einem land von dem
wir wissen dass der amerikanische
präsident im zweifel per exekutivorder
alles was in amerika produziert wird
auch in amerika belässt es ist ja ganz
klar was schiefgelaufen auf jeden fall
für mich beim bei der besorgung des
impfstoffes aber warum das frage ich
mich schon länger muss sich keiner
verantworten für die fehler in der
logistik die regierung war dafür
zuständig den impfstoff zu besorgen in
großem maße dann wird die europäische
lösung beim wirtschaftsunternehmen würde
der chef nun verantwortung tragen müssen
warum passiert das nicht bei der
regierung
na gut es ist ja so ein bisschen
demokratie wenn sie so wollen kommt ja
die sie ist ihre chance ja der regierung
ein zeugnis auszustellen am dann knapp
21 03 und september also dann wenn wir
wählen
das gilt für jedenfalls für deutschland
schon sehr viel schwieriger ist es
natürlich ein brüssel also frau von der
leyen wer soll die eigentlich ablösen
also ein wähler gibt es ja nichts
gesundheit nicht zu sagen in europa
parlament hat auch nichts zu sagen und
die anderen regierungschefs neuer die
haben gar kein interesse daran weil sie
selber sich nicht mit ruhm bekleckert
haben dass von der leyen geht und da
verliert sich dann irgendwann
verantwortung und das ist ja auch etwas
was wir gerade so sehen dass man sich so
ein bisschen gehalt die bälle hin und
her schiebt also ebenfalls den ball der
verantwortung und der schuldfrage
zwischen brüssel und berlin und berlin
im zweifel immer auf brüssels zeigt und
sagt na ja das war doch eine große
europäische initiative dass wir alle
gemeinsam jetzt
sterben herr fleischhauer eine frage die
mich brennend interessiert ich bin ja
großer fan ihrer kolumne muss ich
gestehen an dieser stelle welche frage
hätten sie denn heute abend frau angela
merkel gestellt gab er nicht viel zeit
15 0
aber welche frage wäre so die eine frage
gewesen die in ihnen gebrannt hätte sie
zu fragen heute abend ja ich hätte sie
gefragt also sie sind frau
bundeskanzlerin ja bekannt dafür dass
sie klarer als andere gesehen haben was
im winter auf uns zukommt also wenn es
einen preis dafür gäbe mit prognosen
recht gehabt zu haben und behalten zu
haben den hätten sie gewonnen
aber was haben sie keinen letzten sechs
monaten gemacht welche schlüsse haben
sie alle aus ihren eigenen prognosen
gezogen
so dass wir noch eine frage gewesen ganz
einfach und letzte frage herr
fleischhauer überhaupt 15 minuten klar
kann man immer sagen reicht nicht reicht
ich muss noch mehr muss noch mehr und so
weiter man hat ja auch das eine oder
andere zu tun als bundeskanzlerin
wir waren uns trotzdem vorhinein nicht
naja das erste echte interview nach dem
wohlfühl interview im deutschen magazin
und 15 minuten wir hätten da noch die
eine oder andere frage gehabt war das
knapp bemessen 15 minuten
zumal die bundeskanzlerin ja dann auch
länglicher antwortet und gut 30 minuten
für ein interessanter gewesen aber da
muss man auch mal das ist so da muss man
auch wollen also da muss auch der der
interviewer marjan wollte man sieht ja
auch schon an der ganzen körperhaltung
bei rainer becker also der ist sozusagen
so ein bisschen so in ehrfurcht erstarrt
mein eindruck
wir sind bild und wir liefern die
news auf youtube zum nächsten video
kommst du hier und vergesst bitte nicht
unseren kanal zu abonnieren